all right good morning everyone hear me
all right so I didn't have a title slide
for this talk up until about five
minutes ago and in the spirit of this
song I thought I would just steal their
title slide if you don't get that joke
they stole this song all right I'm here
to talk about well a bunch of things
this talk actually started as a series
of tweets after Google i/o where I was
trolling a bunch of people leading them
to believe I was talking about one
framework when actually I was talking
about the web and I definitely caught
some people with it which was kind of
the point but it really got me thinking
about how we we as Android developers
don't really consider the web as any
kind of first-class citizen we're really
androids been pushing more and more
close to the features of the web and the
web has actually been creeping in on
features of Android to the point where
it's actually getting to the to feature
parity and web apps are not you know a
six letter word anymore
potentially when we usually think about
developing apps for Android iOS or the
web each one has a language that you
think you immediately go to or one or
two for Android we traditionally had
Java now we have Kotlin and there's also
like C and stuff I'm not talking about
that I'm talking more about the managed
language here for iOS
we have Objective C and Swift turns out
objective-c doesn't have a cute logo
like the rest of these so it's not on
any of my slides but but it actually is
still a big thing and then for the web
there's obviously JavaScript and then
typescript is sort of a recent endeavor
bringing you know type safety to the
language but that really really hasn't
stopped people from taking these
languages which were really meant to be
designed and developed for one platform
and trying to use them on other ones
javascript is the one that certainly
comes to mind because browsers are
ubiquitous they're rarely is a piece of
technology that can't run JavaScript and
so just aside from browsers
you know the frameworks that web
developers use tend to get dragged along
once javascript is executing on a
platform so react and react native are
the ones that immediately come to mind
react is interesting because it takes a
paradigm and kind of abstract away the
things that make a platform interesting
and unique and tries the paper over them
allowing you to just focus on the actual
business logic and UI of your code and
have the framework deal with you know
interacting the complexities of
interacting with things like the native
toolkit
you know the problems here is that
JavaScript really wasn't meant to run on
these devices and the language of
JavaScript is actually fairly complex to
run in a performant manner something
we'll take a look at but the advantages
here are huge you have the ability
because Java scripts dynamic and the
runtime interprets the actual source
code you have the ability to do things
like update your app update the
JavaScript in your app not even while
restarting it you can actually do this
while it's still running the way this
works react native specifically on
Android is they actually embed their own
JavaScript engine called JavaScript core
that's part of WebKit NAIT native
library and then react native it takes
care of you know talking to this native
library over J&I it deals with things
like the main thread and then interacts
with androids UI toolkit for you on iOS
JavaScript core is actually built into
the platform and iOS code runs natively
so they don't have anything like Jay and
I where they have to cross this big
bridge and so they're just in time
inside the runtime and again talking to
iOS is main thread in iOS is UI toolkit
then on the web you have the normal
JavaScript engine which is in chrome v8
which talks to the Dom and renders the
elements and so JavaScript becomes sort
of the baseline here and then the
platform specific integrations allow you
to leverage leverage the UI toolkit of
each platform trying to achieve you know
what is otherwise the holy grail of
right wants run everywhere
rekka natives sort of just a way to get
our feet wet in these cross-platform
frameworks but you know you don't
actually have to use something like that
javascript itself can be used directly
as a way of doing code sharing and so if
we don't think about the actual
integrations with the UI you know v8
JavaScript is intrinsic to the web it's
always there on iOS JavaScript core is
embedded as part of the the operating
system so it's always there and able to
be leveraged and then on Android you can
kind of do this with webview but you
really don't want to you but you can
always bring your own JavaScript engine
on Android you know Chrome is a
multi-platform product and actually runs
on Android
they actually embed the v8 engine in
Chrome so that's something you could do
in your app if you wanted to and then
when I worked at square we adapted this
thing called the duct-tape engine the
reason is that both JavaScript core and
v8 are fairly large and comprehensive
runtime duct-tapes actually rather small
it's about 200 kilobytes so if you have
the need to do this the it lowers the
barrier of entry greatly and certainly
the impact that it has on your app but
the biggest downside of doing something
like this is that you have to write code
that talks to the code that's running
JavaScript from your native platform if
you're not doing something like react
native and so interaction from the
native language is can be problematic
and especially if you just interact with
it directly it has a tendency to leak
leak into the rest of your codebase and
then you become really coupled to it and
a lot of the benefits the perceived
benefits become actually downsides and
so the easiest way to mitigate this is
through abstraction what you can do is
actually take all that code that does
the interaction with the cross-platform
solution and hide it behind an idiomatic
API and what's nice about this is it's
actually the same thing that react
native is doing it's just doing the
opposite its subtracting away the
platform and you're writing just the
common code but if you want to still
lever
something like javascript across
multiple platforms you really need to be
doing the the opposite which is
subtracting away the common codes so
that you get the nice idiomatic
cross-platform API and this way you
don't inflict the pain upwards through
your layers of abstraction to developers
they really just interact with this as
if it were any other library regardless
of whatever platform it's running out
and so javascript has talked about this
a lot like I said because of its
ubiquity and also from efforts like
react native Kotlin is an obvious one to
talk about next but I want to stop over
on Swift first Swift can actually
compile to Android compiles down to
native code this is was this was added
to Swift about two two and a half years
ago now and so it runs doesn't run in
the managed virtual machine like our
Java Kotlin would it turns into native
code so it can run next to like where
you would have C or C++ otherwise and if
you're going to do Swift as a potential
cross-platform solution which is
something reasonable to do you wouldn't
want to do it everywhere you would want
to do that same trick where you abstract
it away this is a really easy way to
just take some code that your iOS team
has already written especially if it's
business logic and well-tested that you
can just kind of essentially steal it
for free and get this nice what is
essentially library written in the
language that you work in and not even
have to know that there's native code
behind the scenes the web can you use
that Swift code on the web well the
answer is no but the answer is no not
because why you think it is and we're
actually going to come back to that and
so Kotlin is a you know a particular
favorite of mine and it's the it's a
language was started as targeting Java
byte code for the JVM JetBrains actually
the community quickly realized that it
could be used on Android and pushed
JetBrains to support it which they very
quickly did and then eventually the idea
of using it to target Java scripts or
native game later but with that they
took a slightly different approach
than other languages unlike what you
would do with something like JavaScript
or swift Colin has a notion of platform
dependent and platform independent code
and so today when you're writing Colin
you're likely writing platform dependent
code where you can reference things like
JDK types Android types if you write
platform specific Kotlin for javascript
you can reference types that are present
in the browser like from the dom and if
you write platform specific native code
you can reference code that's available
in native libraries and when Colin
wanted to do multi platform they came up
with this concept called platform
independent Kotlin we usually just call
it common Kotlin code where you actually
don't have access to any of that and it
works similar to if you've heard of like
partial classes maybe from c-sharp where
the common code can really only
reference common code and other common
libraries and then it has to be adapted
to platform specific Kotlin and then
eventually compiled for that platform
and so what's nice about this is you can
write your Kotlin common code in collin
write your platform specific Kotlin code
or potentially platform specific you
know Java C or JavaScript to perform
that adapting to the platform and then
the consuming side can be written in any
of the native languages intrinsic to
wherever you're targeting so you could
write something and have your JavaScript
your web people consume this with like a
library and to them it would just be
JavaScript or typescript you can write
this and have you can write this as like
a turn it into a jar and then Android
developers or server developers just
consume it as a library or with Kotlin
native you can turn it into a native
binary and just have your C or C++ code
consume it as a native library and so
you still want to use the same
multi-platform abstraction
technique where you hide it behind you
know a nice idiomatic API but the
language is much more enabling here
where it allows you to it's more aware
of the fact that it has the ability to
run on multiple platforms and of course
you don't have to do this heavyweight
abstraction if you're
if your whole app is encompassing all
these things you can just put them all
in one project and have them be modules
so I've talked about the the ways that
we can leverage the languages that are
intrinsic to the platform in across
multiple platforms there's sort of a an
elephant in the room here where you
would think that there's something else
that I'm going to mention and it came
out of Google - set of cross-platform
tools it's used by some teams at Google
for code sharing to really accelerate
how they can build their apps it uses a
programming language that's hard for me
to recommend and in the past I've been
very critical of it on a technical level
and my views on that are really
unchanged if you don't know what I'm
talking about
I'm of course talking about je dois BCE
and Google web toolkit if you don't know
what these are I don't know why we never
see these presented at conferences
although I guess Kevin wherever Kevin is
tends to talk about this sometimes it's
a transpiler for Java source code that
allows you to run Java on iOS through
JFC and the web through Google web
toolkit and what's really cool about
this is being a source transpiler is
that entire libraries written in Java
can survive through this so if you have
your Arc Java protocol buffers or
whatever just pure Java library and you
have it at the source code you can
actually survive this cross compilation
you can run you can leverage those
libraries on the web leverage them for
your native code and obviously still
leverage them for Java and I tend to
think the reason we don't hear about
this is because well we're the Android
developers and we're the ones using Java
and so we don't really care what these
other teams are doing with our code if
you go to a Java Script engineer on the
web and say hey I'm going to reuse your
code on Android they're really not going
to care because they don't have to
change things and that's that that was
us as Android developers and so we don't
really hear about this at least until
Kotlin started becoming a thing and if
if you have teams that we're doing this
you know Kotlin throws the wrench into
this system and you have to potentially
look at something else
and so there are other multi-platform
frameworks like the one that I again
just tried rolling people into thinking
I was going to talk about but I don't
really want to talk about them here I
want to move on because I really don't
want to spend I wasn't trying to spend a
lot of time talking about how to do
multi-platform from the technical level
I actually want to change gears a little
bit and talk about a little bit more
conceptual things before we bring it
back to you technical how many people
have seen this photo before
not many people wow that's surprising I
guess it is a few years ago that this
came out it was a studio complaining
about all the different devices that
they have to test their app on on
Android there was a survey done in 2015
by open signal about sort of the shape
of mobile platforms and they put up this
chart which is all the device sizes that
you would have to target if you were
building an app on Android and this is
in 2015 that was Android this is iOS and
what they said was the iOS ecosystem
makes for good comparison with Android
as it's much easier to design for the
considerably smaller number of
dimensions now when I read this I think
wow that's a that's a really flawed way
of thinking there was no image for the
web though there's just Android and iOS
which were the two platforms you tend to
compare because they're the mobile
platforms but again we forget about the
web so let's try and build our own
screen size chart for what the web looks
like so I started with my browser and
that's the size of my browser and then I
drew rectangles for every other browser
size that's out there because it's
infinite right like the web can be any
size and when you compare this to
Android this was 2015
so what we're before multi-window we're
before picture and picture we're before
the free-form desktop Android what's the
thing it's a really Android is like this
as well there's infinite screen sizes
there's no there's no real exact screen
sizes anymore and then you bring up iOS
again which has changed a little bit to
be fair but we tend to lump Android and
iOS together when really we should be
lumping Android and the web together
because
at least from a design perspective they
are essentially the same infinite screen
sizes and you need to change how you
think about it at WWC this year which is
a lot a couple weeks ago at this point
so Mac OS 12 is going to come out this
year next year's Mac OS 13 they actually
announced that you'll be able to take
devices you'll be they take apps written
for iOS and run them on the desktop now
it's not a whole lot of details about
that but we can assume that they will
exist in the same freeform mode that
apps today on desktop exist which means
in about a year iOS gonna have the same
problem now to their credit there has
been a paradigm shift from more
pixel-perfect to more responsive on an
iOS so hopefully this is less of a
problem and as Android developers I hope
that we've seen things like this before
I stole these from the material design
but if you think about design in terms
of not screen sizes but things like
buckets it becomes a whole lot easier
right and this is how you think about
though this is usually how you think
about the web as well and then within
the system of buckets you know we have
flexible let's say columns that give us
freedom to differentiate not
differentiate for freedom to actually
ignore the differences between things
like you know 720 pixel wide and a 768
pixel wide device and then beyond that
we have the concept of things like break
points where as you reach certain sizes
your app dynamically adjusts to the
available space and content that would
otherwise be present on the screen moves
off screen but it's still available via
an affordance and still in the same
logical location material design covers
this but really there's tons of design
systems that behave this way and since
the web we've determined that the web
from a design perspective is a superset
of mobile and mobile is really trending
towards this this way where there's an
infinite number of screen sizes you
really need to think about this and in
terms of every platform not just
or web all right I want to shift to
operating systems real quick the
Chromebook is a really interesting piece
of what can be done with an operating
system
it's a Linux based OS but chrome is
essentially like the windowing manager
and then two developments recently is
that the Play Store is available for
Chromebooks now this is really
interesting there there used to be
something called arc which was sort of a
simulator for Android and wasn't very
accurate and then you didn't hear
anything for about a year or two years
and what happened was the the teams at
Google were actually rewriting how this
works and so now it's it's completely
different and in theory because this has
as Google Play can pass CTS and CTS is
the test suite that sort of validates
how Android behaves and if that means
that a laptop can essentially validate
itself as an Android device and the way
this works is that the android framework
is running natively in a container on
this linux host all the way up through
all the way down through the hardware
abstraction layer where it actually
talks to the native hardware of the
device so like when you ask for the
display you get the display of the
device when you ask for Wi-Fi you get
the Wi-Fi of the of the Chromebook this
is very different than how we think of
like the emulator running on our
machines where everything is abstract
away it's emulated this is Android
running natively on this system but then
at this year's i/o we got the Android
studio and other Linux apps running and
this is also done using the same trick
which is putting them in a container and
where they can you know interact
natively with the device and also like
consume your battery but when you when
you put these into comparison there's
three systems in play here there's the
original chrome one there's the Android
one and there's the Linux native apps
one and they're all solved with
containers they're all solved with this
abstraction but they're interacting
natively with this shared host and so
I'm gonna kind of come back to the point
that I'm making here but there's so this
is a way that Android
sort of been brought to laptops in a
more native way and I want to change
gears again before kind of circling back
and tying all these things together and
talking about the web coming closer to
to native on Android this was announced
last year at Google i/o which is instant
apps the idea that clicking on a link
anywhere on the web can trigger an
on-demand install of an app and allowing
you to use it right away and so the way
this works is that you have you know
your app and you would generate like a
like a fat apk that has everything
inside of it and that's what a user
would normally install from play but you
also create these these smaller apks one
which has you know the common code of
your app and then ones potentially for
each feature inside the app and so as
the user clicks on a URL these smaller
apk is instead of the one large one is
very quickly downloaded installed and
launched in as a replacement for what
would otherwise be browsing to a web
downloading the web page and running it
but if you think about it you know this
is a very similar model to how the web
already behaves we visit up we go to a
link that link resolves to some content
content is downloaded it's then run
interpreted and then display it and just
like the web instant apps aren't
installed they are but they are cached
so if you click a link once the AP the
smaller PS will be downloaded and
launched navigate somewhere else and
then navigate back it won't actually
have to redownload and the same is true
of the web right there's like caching
you visit a resource once and it's going
to be cached for a certain period of
time and so there's a strong parallel to
be drawn to how the web behaves here but
this is done with native apps this is
native apps behaving much more like the
web and you can upgrade to a full
installation from this instant apps
which is similar to what you can do on
something like a Chromebook when you
visit a web page you can upgrade to you
a chrome app which is like an installed
version of that web page this year at
i/o there was sort of a
revision of instant apps or the
technology behind it which is app
bundles where the idea is instead of
creating in apk for each one of these
modules and features we actually break
them up into their component parts and
so each one of these has a Dex which is
the code that we want to run there's
maybe native code for a couple
architectures and then languages for
each of the locales and now what happens
if we if we want to install this app in
a traditional manner where we otherwise
would have that fat apk that had
everything inside of it Google if you do
this through Google Play it will on
demand create a large apk but that
doesn't have everything inside of it
that's tailored for the specific device
onto which you're installing it and then
later if you do something like change
your locale change your language it can
on-demand download only the additional
bits that are needed load them in
restart the app if you're not installing
the full evk and you're doing something
similar to what instant apps is doing
you can actually only download not only
the part of the app that you care about
but only the parts of that part that are
relevant to your device so if you're if
you're running this on you know mobile
phone set to English and you only care
about that one feature you could
download this really tiny apk and then
as you navigate throughout the app and
reach other features they can be
downloaded on the fly and again this
looks very similar to how the web
behaves right we make a request to web
server it determines what resources it
needs to send us determines what
language it should be showing us based
on things like the accept language
header and so this is now Google Play
doing something very similar to that now
unfortunately app bundles actually don't
play well with instant apps there there
are two separate concepts that are in
similar spirit and if you look at the
documentation thankfully the team
apparently is going to reconcile this
and allow the much smaller app bundles
to be used in the context that instant
apps are which is you navigate to a URL
and and you want that tiniest bundle to
be downloaded on the fly okay this is
sort of the opposite view of instant
apps where the though we were taking
something which was supposed to be the
web and on the fly replacing something
behind the scenes that actually made it
a native app on Android you can actually
do the opposite through Chrome where you
can add either a webpage can prompt you
to install the the web page as a native
app or you can do it manually which is
done here through the overflow menu
where I'm taking this really useful app
that plays an airhorn sound and
installing it as a native app and you
can see that it actually puts not only
does it put an icon on the launcher but
it actually is a native APA that you can
you know drag into settings and see that
it is a real apk this is something
called web apks on Android it's a
feature of Chrome but it's it's not
specific to Chrome it's actually
something that's a larger endeavor on
the web in general you may have heard of
progressive web apps which is extremely
similar not exactly the same it's sort
of built upon this idea of progressive
web apps and it leverages this thing
called the web app manifest the web app
manifest is very similar to what we as
Android developers think of as our
Android manifest it's a way of declaring
resources and functionality that your
app has and look this is from a website
called can I use it allows you to figure
out whether or not you can what features
of the web you can use on which browsers
the ones for this specifically we care
about are the mobile browsers you can
see all four here and then align the
line that's highlighted in black is sort
of the current version and so we can see
this is actually not only supported on
Chrome and the other browsers of Android
but it's supported on mobile Safari iOS
Safari so this concept works on
iOS as well and it turns out that when
you start looking at the web and you
start looking at functionality like this
where you can take a what is otherwise a
website that exists inside a browser and
pull it out into what appears like a
native app when you start looking at the
features and functionality that the web
provides it looks really similar to the
kind of things we use as Android
developers to build native apps they
have a concept called circle
serviceworkers which are like background
services a background sync API which is
sort of like job scheduler it allows the
app to actually run in the background
while you don't have the tab open in a
browser or you don't have that web apk
actually open in a PWA it has
notifications that are shown that can be
shown to the user it has a push API
which is like GCM or FCM whatever it's
called this month camera and microphone
access the location of the device that's
around it we can draw GL to get graphics
similar to games we can actually get
input from VR devices to get the the 3d
positioning that that's required to
actually do VR and then Chrome is
experimenting with ones that provide
even more access to hardware which is
Bluetooth or you can the web can
interact with Bluetooth devices and even
USB actually at Google the way we flash
builds of the Android operating system
pre-release ones is through a website
that uses ADB over web USB all right so
the features are there of the web that
bring them at least the the big ones to
parity with you know native apps but are
we really like able to blur the line
between you know if we do this web APK
install can we really like blur the line
where we can fool the user to not really
knowing the difference between these two
things I don't think that's true yet
there's two big problems with this the
one that's how
of apps are executed you know we have
this VM that chooses either an
interpreter a just-in-time compiler or
an ahead of time compiler to run the
actual code and those each talk to the
CPU and execute the the dalvik bytecode
that we have in our our apks on the web
for something like Chrome the majority
of the runtime that's actually executing
this is in v8 which is native code so
the art is doing very little the v8
interacts with the file system where the
actual JavaScript and HTML are cached
and then it only has an interpreter and
just-in-time compiler just-in-time
compiler which talk to the CPU so we
can't do anything like ahead of time
compilation and the other problem is
JavaScript itself is a source based
language which means it has to parse and
interpret what you meant by the source
code before it can even get to a
representation that it can then compile
to something more efficient and on
native if we get all kinds of little
cheats that the web can't do so for
example art will take the just-in-time
compiled or ahead of time compiled
machine code and actually persist that
back to disk so the next time you launch
the app it doesn't have to do a bunch of
work to recompile the byte code into
machine code it can just load what it
already did and you get immediate fast
execution
if we actually if you've been hearing
about what's going on in the web there's
an effort which is called web assembly
which is the idea of bringing byte code
to the web getting away from JavaScript
which is this not only is its source
base but like it's kind of not that
great of a language and I think even
most JavaScript developers will tell you
this although to their credit the last
few years they've done an amazing job at
iterating at this language it just
really has a lot of legacy baggage and
web assembly is a chance to not only
push a reset button but to bring things
like performance where it otherwise
wouldn't have existed and so if we go
back to when I was talking about Swift
running on the web the reason I said no
is actually not because there's any
technical limitation behind this it's
just that no one has written a web
assembly converter for this yet but it
is technically possible and there
actually are efforts to do this and so
in theory in the future there should be
nothing preventing you from taking that
Swift code compiling it to the web
assembly bytecode and then having that
run in the browser the same is true for
Collins so even though Kotlin jas is a
thing you can target JavaScript you can
take the native Colin through Kotlin
native and use web assembly to get the
faster execution and so this should
speed up the the web apps the web in
general but also the the web apks that
we've installed compilation complexity
becomes pushed to the developer instead
of having to happen at runtime through
interpretation there's so that solves
one of the problems that I believe is
really holding back the the true
blurring of this line but you still have
the problem where well hold on okay you
still have the problem where this apk is
not behaving the same as native in the
sense that the runtime is different and
if we if we do this installation and
look at what's inside this apk we can
open this in Android studio and you see
that one of the cool things that we got
for free is that when this apk is
installed it actually has an intent
and so from anywhere in the system if
you navigate to this URL it'll actually
launch the the web apk installed app
which is a cool behavior where if the
user goes installs like the Twitter web
apk and then click a Twitter link from a
chat app you know actually it won't
launch the browser this web apk will
intercept it and you'll get the native
web experience but elsewhere in the
manifest you see that well it's kind of
hard to see but there's the URL of the
web app in here and if you look into the
byte code of the main apk you don't need
to read it but it pulls out this URL and
then intense out to Chrome and so what's
happening is this web weak web apk is
really just like a jumping pad back into
the old way that chrome is rendering
things what I'd much rather see is this
web apk that's being installed be
brought like much closer to what that
native app is we're inside the dex file
it's a truly stand-alone system where
maybe the v8 runtime is actually either
shared or copied into this and executes
natively in this process there's huge
advantages to be had here where you
could leverage something like job
scheduler to determine when the user has
the screen off and the phone is charging
and you could do ahead of time
compilation where you can take that web
assembly run it through the v8 compiler
turn it into machine code and then
persist it back in the applications
cache folder so when the user clicks
that web APK the next time it's actually
just running machine code I haven't
talked about this earlier but
permissions and notifications those are
features that are available on the web
but when you're running them in chrome
chrome becomes the app that's not only
blamed for notifications and permissions
when a website uses them perhaps and
properly but if you look throughout the
system and try to disable notifications
for a website you have to do it through
chrome you have to do it through the
normal interface you want to revoke a
permission you do it through chrome not
through the normal interface by having
each web app web apk turn into a proper
apk those could be then blamed not in a
negative sense of the word but
maybe correlated or associated with the
actual installed web IBK and setup with
chrome and yeah didn äôt I talked about
that okay so it's active have a lot of
these a lot of different concepts here
and I want to really quickly try and
paint a picture where I bring them all
together and I'm gonna use Colin because
Colin is like programming language Jesus
for me it's the one that I think you
should be using but really I don't care
if you're if you're doing something like
this use whatever works whether it's C
another language from a search engine
company but I'm gonna pick Colin here's
all the line draws by the way so in a
modular eyes app where you have a bunch
of common common code you know you have
like your networking stuff through
database stuff and in this Kotlin since
it's written in Kotlin common modules
that any part of any implementation can
consume and then maybe we write some
like feature modules which are the
features that we actually want to show
to our our consumers of this app through
whatever mechanism they're consuming it
then those adapts adapt these libraries
into actual like value propositions of
the app and then we want to come up with
an android client so we adapt those four
features and to say android UI and then
we create instant apps and baby yeah
where they called Android bundles out of
each one so that they can be shipped in
a bundle and then we also create the
module which does like the fat apk for
legacy users or users of app stores
which are not Google Play and so we get
out an apk and we get out an app bundle
of each individual feature and then
you're like oh when we write an iOS app
so I write an iOS a set of features
which maybe adapt those and actually
create the UI for iOS and then we bring
those all together and we spit out an
IPA which is the the format for Apple
apps then we also have the web so we
write through the UI for the web we pull
those together and spit those out into
our website and then finally we have
like our back-end which is
leveraging a bunch of the common modules
as well for business logic when we get
this world where with whatever language
you choose there's a bunch of shared
business logic there's a bunch of shared
features and so the source of truth for
this is always is always common and yet
we have the ability to adapt that into
what's native for the platform but even
doing this well it looks pretty
especially with all those cotton logos
on there it's really not enough because
we need to remember the other principles
that we talked about where every
platform needs to be thinking in a
responsive fashion whether it's the
Android app running on maybe a TV or a
tablet if an Android tablet still exists
running on an iPad running on an iPhone
running on a web browser running on a TV
running on a web browser running on a
flip phone we need all of these adapt
all of these apps to adapt and by
thinking of them all with the same
design system that actually becomes
really easy and then finally what's
really cool about this whether you use a
single language multiple languages to
achieve this is that no matter how the
user gets into your system they're
treated with a really nice experience
and so if we just have Android in the
web they click a link and maybe in some
hypothetical future where instant apps
and app bundles become married they get
a just-in-time apk spun specific for
their device and it all works
or maybe they visit Google what's this
one or they visit a Google Play and they
click install and they get the same
thing but through a different through a
different onboarding experience non
Google Play app store
well here they we get like the fat apk
that you built what's this one oh the
other one was a Play Store but this
one's Play Store I guess a be
Chromebooks maybe they visit Google Play
in a Chromebook well now they get the
apk with different architecture with the
different icons inside of it because the
display is different
if they're still on a Chromebook and
they visit through the web maybe they
can install the the Chrome App version
of your website or if they're just
visiting inside Chrome or the link
through another from another website
they just navigate to the URL if they're
chrome on the browser they can then go
through it install the web apk or if
they're just getting a link they can
still follow the URL and then we can't
forget about our friends on the other
side of the fence which is we you know
if we spat on an IPA of this we can get
the native experience on iOS as well if
they're visiting through Safari if they
go to the URL they can obviously still
do that but because the the web app
manifest is something supported by
Safari they can do their version of the
web apk which is the progressive web app
that installed to their home screen and
get the native like experience and then
next year in the hypothetical feature of
Mac OS 13 they'll be able to install
that the the native app the native
version of your app for iOS on their Mac
and then finally if they're in an
existing app and they hit a URL like
that app intents out to a URL or
whatever the equivalent of it a tenth is
on iOS
they obviously still have the ability to
fall back to the web and so and these
all interact right like so if you're you
can bounce around between them you can
have upgrade experiences through them
but no matter what your user is being
served and what's nice is that if you
think about the slide two slides ago
they're all being served by the same I
said like back-end in the sense of the
word that the code that backs it and so
if we can get to this point regardless
of the language that it's done in if you
can get the technology of how you build
the app to the point where you can
leverage that sharing to the ridiculous
degree if you can get the designers on
your team to leverage the design system
where it becomes not only consistent
across platforms in the sense that your
app looks and behaves the same but it's
responsive across platforms and the idea
that every every platform needs to be
responsive and you can deploy these
things to all the particular locations
you end up producing a really nice
where it becomes irrelevant whether the
user is experiencing rap through the web
or through the native apk because they
truly shouldn't have to care no matter
how they get into into your apps
experience they should have the best
experience possible for that particular
platform and ideally we can lose things
like the giant banners that say you know
install install the native app instead
of visiting my website which shouldn't
actually matter because it's the same
code it's the same responsive design and
it's the same experience across every
platform and then you know while this is
painting a very pretty picture there's a
lot of work to get to this but it feels
more closer than ever and so as long as
we stay sort of vigilant about wanting
to paint this future hopefully we can
get to the point where these lines truly
are blurred that's all I got thank you
[Applause]